hello and welcome to this blitz video I
hope this is working alright seems so
even got the right video number and I
think yeah I'm playing black iam against
the shadow killer that's not a very nice
username Yuri wants to kill me
even in the shadows a good idea okay I'm
playing them c-45 English an opening
that I've employed quite a bit now in
blitz chess and I tried in in classical
over the war chest but didn't didn't yet
get it on the board
okay so white is going form d4 it seems
maybe slow in a slow way yeah I'm taking
this opportunity to gain a tempo on on
the h3 pawn he's probably out for deform
[Music]
yeah I can always take that and play d5
so I don't think it's a huge deal
[Music]
plays it you know let's do it let's take
interesting question there how he wants
to capture now rook b8 was played in
order to go with b5 that is not yet or
not anymore it's the right way to phrase
it not anymore and possibility even
though you can't play B five years on
completely terrible but normally he
would do this some play to yeah
to provoke this kind of development now
here I need to get my Bishop back into
the game with c6 Bishop to b8 I'm quite
happy here this should be a fine
position long term
I have ideas Jim I came yeah okay he
tries to get my bishop and in fact he
will get the bishop but I'm not sure is
how bad is that really if he takes a way
it's not a big deal
let him oops let him take it it doesn't
matter now the remaining okay he doesn't
take it after all the remaining pieces
would would have been fine
[Music]
I want my knight on f5 making trying to
provoke we're trying to get some
pressure on d4 but that's not so easy to
do another interesting way to plan would
be Bishop f5 and then maybe maybe go for
this and then 96 get to get rid of this
I would really like to get something
going on like on the Kings side but it's
not easy to do my bishop he is pointing
right right at his king but yeah those
pieces here the bishop in nineteen make
it difficult to advance pawns
I would like to advance the F pawn or
let's end it so we had move what is the
knight doing there I don't know okay
I'm happy that I'm able to play this him
f3 is not a move you want to play
probably it's even directly bad I'm
weakening g3 like that and I don't mind
to trade him now I'm I think a little
bit a little bit better
[Music]
my night and it-it's not not great on g6
but so maybe doing a little bit more
than the d39 and my bishop on b8 is
definitely better than the one would be
to it that's that's really the main
reason why I think I should be a little
bit better him now
where is he going yeah this is with the
move like Queen c7 you can you can
threaten knowledge form it's a very
cheap trick it's a very cheap trick come
on okay
yeah it's a kind of Queen c7 is not a
great move at the minutes it's a little
cheapo that you can try without risking
anything so yeah okay I think before he
blundered down I was just a little bit
better not much maybe the engine
evaluates it is equal that's very much
possible so this is a good line here
White has a choice between mostly
developing to f3 as he did or III both
certainly fine and Tim yeah one key idea
that I learned after looking at this
line a little bit deeper yes that 97 is
an interesting way to play this not to
go to f6 which looks a little bit more
natural but the idea of this move is
that whenever he goes III d4 that denied
often sorry has a good a good idea to go
to f5 and yeah there are some others but
this is a main a main thing Castle it's
interesting that the engine wants to go
f6 but should be six directly yeah you
can do that something wrong about it I I
went with h6 to to be sure that 95
doesn't hit me to Bishop e6 I think oh
this is quite normal yeah and now rook
b8 is a typical idea here with b5 if you
can get in rupee 1 b5 it's more
difficult for white to play d4 as c4 is
always under pressure if you imagine I
can put it on the board if you imagine
let's say you play the slowest move you
know this one yeah then this is an idea
it's a controversial idea you don't need
to do it but it's interesting term yeah
get some imbalance going and here it's
now more difficult for white to play d4
where Queen c2 didn't help with d4
anyway but this way with the pressure on
c4 it's more of a stretch for him to get
d4
we play d4 immediately after which I
should take an idea I somewhat agree
with the engine that gives each takes d4
is a little bit better in comparison the
reason it's just that like if you look
at this the same structure pawn
structures in the game it is quite
favorable for me that those two pieces
are traded because it's easier for me
now within the game as you compare that
it's easier for me now to get in this
and this Bishop back to b8 activate it
again so this is a little bit thing
preferable for white
maybe b6 is indeed an idea at the end it
shows it suggests to immediately get the
bishop back into the game
so here it's rather easy to take and you
go here yeah that that's true I was
thinking about this during the game
Bishop e3 isn't move but I felt I can
just play rook e8 and ignore the whole
thing if you if you imagine this like it
takes I take and now I was white
supposed to win the pawn something like
this is not a big problem I will always
get the fall back and then I'm probably
even better no on this is also not great
I mean somehow it works out I was just
starting to look at it during the game
and then he already played c5 and then I
didn't want to mention it okay who
creates normal we get this to b8 yeah
here of course I can also move the
bishop away I felt that the capture only
six doesn't hurt me at all but she
didn't take it I would have taken with
the Queen f takes looks wrong it looks
like a rather weakest pawn yeah probably
you get an e5 but anyway I would have
done that and then my idea was to if
possible light and five Queen f6 and
putting some pressure on the pawn yeah
and the engine it may vary wait this is
equal which is probably fair I mean I'm
rather black here because I have a clear
idea what to do but it's probably not
nothing significant
so Queen d2 man see I didn't quite know
what to do I mean this is something the
engine actually suggest suggests that
but nothing special it's probably still
equal yeah and it gets a bit hot with
this move this is not a good move and
now it turns out that I had even this
one oh I would have been very strong
actually threatening Knight G - Bishop
h3 Wow no didn't occur to me at all and
this is a strategically good move I
thought it engine doesn't agree 95 I
didn't see 95 I just thought that this
is strategically very desirable to trade
the bishops and I didn't really look for
anything concrete but Knight age 4 is
really strong I mean it's got no good
move there
it's basically lost already okay yeah
but this is interesting I didn't didn't
think about this at all
which is kind of sad it's a
normal-looking move I still don't quite
understand okay now the engine is going
down to a equal assessment first of all
foot first it gave white a slight
advantage then I would that that I don't
believe it really and all that is a
slight advantage Queen d8 is supposed to
be best according to the engine if that
is the slight advantage for ride
I do understand if white manages to get
the pawns rolling that he's better but
to say I really do that maybe I'm like
this
f4 h5 this kind of situation yeah yeah
white is probably a little bit better
engine is now going down to 0-0 ish but
yeah okay and then know what I've done
what I would have done there probably I
would have played that we should take
the five queen d8 doesn't feel very
intuitive to me the issue is that here
I'm probably fine young because this is
not possible
the queen is unprotected and and
something like this is definitely fine
for black yeah here them the weaknesses
and meta bishop arms are important so
it's probably around equal yeah white
play some something slow and then just
take them yeah Queen da this best
probably would have done that okay rook
e3 I still can't play Knight edged
forward ahead
I didn't didn't spot this idea I was
simply thinking in strategy and
concluding that I should be slightly
better here
yeah Ruby for is the non trick move
let's say but this is kind of yeah I'm
not risking anything and it can set this
little trap rookie one yeah this is
actually what I expected to happen you
know and now I cannot do it yeah and
there's just a square on everyone and
yeah here I have given up some some part
of my advantage so Queen c7 is not best
ready the engine wants to go looky form
you know makes all sense of Hank taking
an eye on that and preparing to increase
the pressure on the you farm yeah but
okay the little trick worked
I was tempted also to do that because I
was
about a minute lower on the clock so
that you have cause for quick winds as
possible
yeah thanks a lot for watching